If you want to see the epitome of management
by optics, a term that we've been discussing
more and more lately, I have it for you today.
Look no further than CEOs told to remove their
masks before Mike Pence comes out to meet
with them.
Imagine that people around Mike Pence have
tested positive.
Three people that we know of connected to
the White House have the virus.
More are in quarantine.
Pence's press secretary has the virus.
Katie Miller, she happens to be the wife of
Trump adviser Steven Miller.
Pence should be in quarantine, but is simply
not doing it.
He has a meeting over the weekend with food
industry CEOs.
They show up wearing masks, all five of them.
They're doing the right thing.
Someone from Pence's staff comes out or someone
guided by his staff comes out and tells them,
take off your masks before the vise president
comes out here.
We actually have video of this.
You don't even have to wonder how it went
down.
We're playing the video for
our TV audience.
You actually see someone come out.
All of the CEOs are wearing masks.
She goes up to the CEOs.
You see her say something and she actually
mimics the motion of mask removal.
And they all do it, by the way.
Notice how she's not wearing a mask.
She gets right up in the faces of these five
CEOs.
This is actually close enough to spread the
virus.
There is no explanation for this other than
image and optics.
This was hours after Pence's own press secretary
tested positive for a corona virus.
And the Trump administration has turned the
mask into a political element rather than
excuse my might on a phrase here.
It's a political element rather than a well,
an element of medical for lack of a better
term now.
OK.
That's sort of a joke.
But this is merely a public health item
and it is now being used politically.
If people all around Pence are wearing masks
and Mike Pence is not, it could make much
Mike Pence look bad.
But it also makes it seem like it's unsafe
out there.
And people have to be worried about getting
the virus, which they do.
And that is why people are not allowed to
be masked up around Mike Pence during this
roundtable.
And it's all about pretending everything's
normal.
It's about being economic warriors for the
stock market.
Trump is increasingly using that term.
Economic warriors before people were warriors
for staying home.
Now they're warriors for not staying home.
It's completely Orwellian.
Kaley McInerney was asked about it at a recent
press briefing and reporters were confused
because at first it was I thought I thought
people were staying home.
And that was that was the war we were fighting.
But
now it's people are warriors by no longer
staying home and just getting out there.
And McCann and he said, that's right, they're
all warriors.
When they were staying home, they were warriors
now being out there, warriors.
And as usual, these things become vicious
circles and self-fulfilling prophecies because
the CDC recommended first responders wear
masks starting in very early April.
Now, they didn't have them available.
Police departments, fire departments, et cetera,
needed to find the masks.
But that was the recommendation starting on
April 3rd.
That was five weeks ago.
Imagine how much better off we would be and
how much better off the economy would be.
This is a point I keep making.
If on April 3rd, everybody started wearing
masks.
If on March 5th or 7th or 10th, Donald Trump
said, hey, 50 governors, let's do a stay at
home 30 days, you probably end
up having to extend it 15 or 30 more.
That would be over by now.
We would be done with that.
Trump just pretending that everything is fine.
It also won't work for the country.
Tons of people are going to die.
But this make believe, play pretend stuff
that the Trump administration is doing about
business as usual.
It can work for a few weeks, but if the numbers
don't improve, it's going to implode.
We have five and a half months left before
we will get the opportunity to remove every
last one of these people.
And we have to not allow a lot of the stuff
we've talked about today on all needs to happen.
We can't allow this stuff to become normal.
We can't become numb to it.
The hyper normalization happens naturally.
To some degree.
Humans just adapt to what's going on.
If you're used
to seeing fifteen hundred to twenty five hundred
people a day die of corona virus if it happens
for long enough.
And most people's lives remember, we're a
country of 331 million.
Most people's lives seem sort of stable.
It's very easy for that to become normal.
Much the same way the continued insistence
or sort of make believe is essentially what
it is about.
Everything's fine.
The economy's opening.
Here's a list of states opening.
Testing is great.
It's all great.
That does.
Work and we need to fight really hard to make
sure that we don't fall
for it.